Oh everyone got the prozac ready
seriously pop one of those bad boys
about 30 minutes for watching this movie
cuz holy [ __ ] southpaw to South boss
directed by Antoine Fuqua ultimately
it's a story with Jake Gyllenhaal he's
this big-time boxer he's super
successful he's undefeated his life
takes a turn for the worst and the worst
and then the worst and worst worst worst
were downward down and down down the
rabbit hole of [ __ ] we go seriously mad
this movie was one of those things where
you're watching you're like I can't get
worse oh look at that it did it just got
worse for him and if that is the goal of
this movie if the goal of this movie is
for you to feel sorry and terrible bad
for this guy success movie you did it
first of all Jake Gyllenhaal was awesome
in this movie dude it's like Christian
Bale at this point he transforms his
body he gets into his roles this
Nightcrawler like 9 months ago now he's
this dude holy [ __ ] and he really got
into this role man when this dude's in
emotional agony you get it you get it
you feel it you know it you're there and
usually when CPS gets involved in movies
you know you're supposed to root for the
main character you're like oh man let
him see his kid yeah that [ __ ] sucked
Essene mrs. Doubtfire we're rooting for
Robin Williams here this movie's one of
the few movies I've seen room like yeah
it's probably best for the kid that she
doesn't actually see her dad right now
he's kind of an unstable dude dude has
some crazy anger management issues I did
like how the movie reflects that you
know I mean he's a fighter that's what
he knows he knows just lashing out that
there was this big strength in the ring
this movie shows is kind of like the
lesson of live by the sword die by the
sword you live a whole life like that if
you take it outside the ring [ __ ] you're
going to crash and burn very badly if
you just don't let some things go if he
says really good in this movie too he's
kind of like the Don King of this movie
now he's the opportunist he's the boxing
promoter you know his role he does his
role really well
Horace Whitaker was great in this movie
too you can tell it a movie like they're
just like birds of a feather you know
they're all boxers they all know the
life that they had and have it just all
of them are damaged in some way shape or
form and I really like that the thing
about this movie is that you are power
gulping depression when you watch it
seriously holy [ __ ] I mean you know this
dude's gonna like find a path he's gonna
start directing his life at a point in
the movie but I could have done for it
happening earlier in
because it just goes from bad to worse
to worse it seriously these people right
here they're like not as bad of a
downward spiral is that movie holy God
call me sappy I just would have liked to
have seen it happen earlier on in the
movie like say the last half of the
movie not the last third of the movie or
the quarter of the movie or when it
happens in this movie in that I feel
like the movies baiting you like he's
just beating you over the head with
badshah's like here feel it feel it
feeling you're like I'm feeling good
stop please stop and in that when you
hear the premise of this movies like oh
it's a boxer who had everything and then
lost everything and then there's what
happens in the movie you know what's
gonna happen you know he's gonna kind of
find a path and then start course
correcting himself as much as the
execution in this movie is abnormally
depressing it's kind of predictable and
where the movies going to come
ultimately guys I give it up for the
cash in this movie because everyone of
this movie did a great job they're all
great actors once again Jake Gyllenhaal
kills it he's not gonna get an Oscar or
anything because if he didn't for
Nightcrawler he's just not going to for
this but he was great in the movie
everyone was great in the movie the
movie gives you the feels it makes you
feel whether you want to or not I will
say southpaw is a good time no alcohol
required although you might want to have
a couple shots after the movie Jesse are
so southpaw have you seen it what did
you think about it what's your favorite
boxing movie of all time whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more